Uh,
I haven't heard from them yet
to distinguish themselves from the AfD and the danger of the AfD
its planned party will be a common cause with the
with the AfD,
make common cause with the AfD rule out,
do some things.
It is a matter of course,
we will not do common things with the AfD.
I mean,
we bring a party
to the state so that all the people,
which also as Anger From Despair but just not
because they are right
think about it now
AfD to vote for or have already done so,
so that these people have a serious address.
And I think,
when you have heard our word contributions at the beginning uh.
After all,
both Christian Leyer,
miramor with Ali as well as me
positioned in this question.
But I find
it would be good for the political debate in Germany,
if we can learn more about reasonable policies
and would talk less about the AfD.
I would like to say the same about that.
In their press release
they deplore an authoritarian style of politics,
but is 1 party leader called bündniserer
does not warn the core
also authoritarian.
I don't know what they come up with.
So of course you can say,
if a party bears the name of a person,
then that is first of course strong uh
personalized.
But that is a temporary solution.
This will not be the case in the long run.
But of course,
when you start a new party,
she has to establish herself first.
And uh,
i just ask them to uh think about it,
what this will look like in the elections,
for example.
There is a long ballot.
It will definitely be like this in the federal election,
that uh I can only run in one state.
That is the right to vote in Germany.
So I will
for 15 federal states
are not on the ballot at all.
However,
people must be able to identify,
which party it is.
So.
And that's where we decided,
that's why to take my name here.
But this will not be a permanent solution.